O!Sapiens Expert: Consumable.
FANATIC Agency: Вам слышно, как у меня тут сосят. Решил Пелить деревья.
O!Sapiens Expert: No.
FANATIC Agency: Нет?
Антон Аверьянов: Yes, yes.
FANATIC Agency: Просто чувак. Короче. Ну. Видимо купил. Квартиру на. Первом этаже.
FANATIC Agency: Она очень долгое время. Там никто не Жил но, она заросла у. Меня просто напротив пятиэташка?
O!Sapiens Expert: Uh-huh.
FANATIC Agency: Кленом заросли но соответственно, прям, перед, его окнами он значит все выходные. Ябался с ножовкой ну просто обычная, такая вот Я не смотрю. Дума. Блячева, как, мне тебя жалко думала ну, Как бы Дать, ему папы тут дохирав всего. Потом, думах у меня это, Надо. Я Сейчас Ему что, то?
FANATIC Agency: Ну. Короче, Я не хочу вступать в комникате с людьми лишний раз видим он короче.
O!Sapiens Expert: Okay.
FANATIC Agency: Утал через купил бромбит на нее новая такая бензопила. И он как. Знаете. Чувак. Такой Вот из, фильмах Ужасов Который бегает бензопилой, и, всех пирачит он прям удовольствием. И вашет, этот калеон, продолжает?
O!Sapiens Expert: I'm gonna keep yours.
FANATIC Agency: Наверно, да.
O!Sapiens Expert: Let's see what else we have here.
FANATIC Agency: Немогу?
O!Sapiens Expert: Miyoshi.
FANATIC Agency: Убить. Да?
O!Sapiens Expert: You don't even need to put a shot.
O!Sapiens Expert: I don't know why I don't know.
FANATIC Agency: Арин, Привет?
Arina Mokrousova: Привет, а я у вас, как яндек Айфон Какой, то, мне познала?
O!Sapiens Expert: Cook tea.
Антон Аверьянов: Talk to you.
Антон Аверьянов: Exactly.
Arina Mokrousova: Что?
Arina Mokrousova: Как я?
Arina Mokrousova: Ну Давайте. Абсурдно сначала наше темо а Потом. Я пойму кас я?
Arina Mokrousova: Донус?
Arina Mokrousova: Есть, что обсудить?
O!Sapiens Expert: Hmm.
FANATIC Agency: Да, Да, Ну, собственно, у нас, еще давайте наверно. С?
FANATIC Agency: Кате начнем. У Нас из задачей. У. Нас типа два, стрема наверно, по, кате стрим, первый, это финансовый. И. Стрим. Второй. Чем мы будем делать с теми проектами, на которых она задействована в собственно сентябре.
FANATIC Agency: А вот?
Arina Mokrousova: Тут. Хочется. Давайте. Нервиться. Со Второго начнем. Тут Хочется. Против антон немножко рассказал. Пока, Мне про. Это сказала, и какая, У вас. Есть договоренность про что мы, уже не знаем может, она там условна что, тут доводит как, фрил остается, как обычно, идеюсь агентства уходит там и так далее. Про это не знаем потом расскажи. Немного?
Arina Mokrousova: Черная обще. Тебе, сказала, и?
Arina Mokrousova: Есть Ли у вас с ней договоренности там Что Она там какие, то? Задачи, да, водит? Не Знаю, там?
Антон Аверьянов: Мы с не собственно, созводились У нас был ван ту ван Но мы, на, ним, хотели обсудить еще это штуку с странаром, который она там говерлась сидела и, так далее?
Arina Mokrousova: Для споковано?
Антон Аверьянов: Но, Ну, на, да, совместно, со, скольку, оно вообще. Для нас Начала Говорят и просто хотели следующий реток по методологии посмотреть. Созвонились. И Но я вижу, что то, нерешительно, и такое случилось, но только что антон Типа я.
Антон Аверьянов: Ухожу, мне сделали офиг?
Антон Аверьянов: Окей, Кто, сделал накарит сбер?
Антон Аверьянов: Я не стал спрашивать на, что она говорит что, в, Общем она сейчас ищет стабильность а?
Антон Аверьянов: Для нее предложили кратер зарплаты на. Общем нела, решение окей че будем Тогда, обсуждать?
Arina Mokrousova: Угу?
Arina Mokrousova: Трандродар?
Антон Аверьянов: Тот, для чего собрались да?
Arina Mokrousova: Угу?
Антон Аверьянов: Ты настоешься где. С Каким? То образом включено она? Такая да? Я, Проговаривала?
Антон Аверьянов: С работодателем что. Могу. Ли Я Вести какие то проекты которые, не влияют, того, что нету никакого конфликта, интересов с по име, на основном месте и, сказали что, да.
Arina Mokrousova: Угу?
Антон Аверьянов: Вот поэтому, но?
O!Sapiens Expert: Yeah, but I don't know how to do it.
O!Sapiens Expert: I don't know if it's true or not, but I think it's true.
O!Sapiens Expert: I don't know.
Антон Аверьянов: Окей, Она, Ну, мне. Тоже, Кажется, что там не, так много будет возможности его какого. То включения, и особенно, на, первых. Парах я. Би На это не. Рассчитывал?
Антон Аверьянов: Она. Три недели дорабатывает мы. Детали Никакие дни. Обсуждали. Сказала что, три, недели, она еще включена.
Антон Аверьянов: За три недели надо. Довести би эс до Какого, то состояния там поймем, сегодня, а после, презентации. Чего. От Нас с банком?
Антон Аверьянов: Его надо как то, передавать, вот, думать, что делать?
Arina Mokrousova: Дело. В том что, у меня не только эти проекты у. Меня еще новая косметика которая поват, и на ней завязано?
Антон Аверьянов: Это на сказал, да? Ведет?
Arina Mokrousova: Как она собирается довести в фокус? Группы?
Антон Аверьянов: А Там. Фокус. Группы. Ну, да Надо?
Антон Аверьянов: Да?
Антон Аверьянов: Надо снять поговорить. Я от Дом. Косметика на завтра играл?
Антон Аверьянов: Так, она там. Фокус группы, и потом, что она с там, с ними?
FANATIC Agency: Хд?
Антон Аверьянов: Да, И потом мы забираем это.
Антон Аверьянов: А сколько? Там по времени сейчас? Будет вкус? Группети?
FANATIC Agency: Неделя четыре. Там. Шесть фокус. Группа.
Антон Аверьянов: Ну. Я, думаю надо, будет просто проговорить что, думаю, рассчитываем. Что, на проект это доведет?
Антон Аверьянов: Каким то образом?
Антон Аверьянов: Чтобы из за ближайшие три недели прошла это, то активная, часть?
Антон Аверьянов: Скуку, с группами, где насильно включена?
FANATIC Agency: Она не пройдет. Ну. Давайте. Давайте. Прям Предметно, всегда, говорить она рабатывает до одиннадцатого она. Написала про. Это просто. Ане колягиной?
FANATIC Agency: Вот по документам. То есть у нас нет трех недель. У нас есть две недели?
FANATIC Agency: То что сегодня уже пятница собственного плять. Четверг ну. Короче.
FANATIC Agency: Вот, получается, что она уходит одиннадцатого числа. И сейчас, вот это тайбе сто что, на нее завязано наверно. Нужно, Ставить фул?
FANATIC Agency: Чтоб она его делала Вот эти вот тренды которые, есть сейчас.
FANATIC Agency: Потому, что здесь сложно ее кем, то, заменить это первый это?
Антон Аверьянов: Да?
FANATIC Agency: Первый момент второй. Момент снова косметик здесь. Нужно просто принимать решения допустим. С Ней поговорить не знаю, там, поставить, на, понедельник с ней какую. То, встречу и проговорить возможность если, она действительно готова?
FANATIC Agency: Ввести этот проект. Как Фрил?
FANATIC Agency: И подключаться на фокус группы. Я просто не понимаю, если она выйдет уже в сбер?
FANATIC Agency: Там не знаю там с четырнадцатого как она, Может подключаться к фокус группам это как? Бы два часа пол работ и, так, далее?
Arina Mokrousova: Мясом, мясом пола?
FANATIC Agency: Вот, если она не выходит еще в сбер сразу, и у нею, есть, какой, то, Гэп?
FANATIC Agency: То окей?
FANATIC Agency: Нет проблем. Давайте. С не договариваться на. На Фрил?
FANATIC Agency: Вот потому, что там у нас остается только одна алиса И здесь нужно, тогда будет принимать решение исходя из. Ответа, кати?
FANATIC Agency: Либо. Мы сюда какого, то фрила подключаем другого, либо, мы вообще отдаем. Этот Этап подрядчиком. Качественного исследования?
FANATIC Agency: А Вот, потому, что внутри мы его сейчас закрыть. Не можу.
FANATIC Agency: Но то, сейчас все зависит от того от кате?
FANATIC Agency: Вот она. Выходит сразу, или не сразу?
Антон Аверьянов: Но я могу нее сегодня спросить потому, что она приедет на т банк и. Давайте. С. Ним. Поставим тогда на понедельник звонок. Может быть на завтра чтобы, мне откладывать и проговоримся, эти. Вещи.
Антон Аверьянов: Они довольно?
FANATIC Agency: Леант?
Антон Аверьянов: Болезне?
FANATIC Agency: Важная?
Антон Аверьянов: Ну. Давай, же да.
O!Sapiens Expert: I don't know. I don't know. I don't know. I don't know. I don't know.
FANATIC Agency: Не, не если смотрите если, она говорит что, я прям с четырнадцатого выхожу?
FANATIC Agency: В сбер, то нам нет смысла на нее стоят фокус. Группы это. Прям. Как, бы сто процентов потому что, мы, не можем ставить шесть человек из фокус группы?
FANATIC Agency: Типа плять, получится, не получится. И вот это. Вот все это для нас очень рискован мы и, так сейчас начинаем двигать старт качественного исследования, потому что у них ера не понимаем кто, его, как, бы будет делать?
FANATIC Agency: Вот.
Arina Mokrousova: Врачном. Быстро. Решение нужно принимать. Вот По новой косметикс, и поэтому нужно быстро, от ее инфа. Лучше. Доставить на пятницу и смотреть на это реалистично вот?
Антон Аверьянов: Завтра дать?
FANATIC Agency: Я не очень просто понимаю, куда там на пятницу впихнуть уже. Встречу?
FANATIC Agency: А у вас только на обед на Твой, арен?
Arina Mokrousova: Угу?
FANATIC Agency: На четырнадцать?
Arina Mokrousova: Ставьте.
FANATIC Agency: Ну Нам там полчаса наверно. Нужно мне, кажется мы, можем?
Arina Mokrousova: Да?
Arina Mokrousova: А какие еще раз унем проект ежений фьючер пров? Ну Вот Ты банк она сейчас довела?
Arina Mokrousova: Альбиэс Новая, Косметика, Четыре Да?
FANATIC Agency: Пионер. Еще есть?
Arina Mokrousova: Ага, Ну там, он, тоже, он, такой такой. Же как фьючерпрув, и как ты банк, уже?
Arina Mokrousova: На піаніє?
FANATIC Agency: Ну, Фьючерпрув, она. Дадо Ведет мне кажется Здесь надо. Просто, допинать, их, чтобы. Они прислали все, материалы?
FANATIC Agency: Тут. Можно, как бы честно сказать валерия егора что, Типа вот, у нас ну не знаю там катя уходит но, нам нужно с ней завершить этот проект пожалуйста. Пришлите, свои материалы побыстрее?
Arina Mokrousova: Угу?
FANATIC Agency: С Пионеры Разберемся, Есличу?
Arina Mokrousova: Ну. Коротше.
Arina Mokrousova: Так, з піонером розбирався вот.
Arina Mokrousova: Тому, що по трендам?
Arina Mokrousova: Ми його. Не зробимо?
FANATIC Agency: Ну Слушай, это в. Это на. Самом деле наверно такой вопрос. Дискусионный Да потому, что, она может, как, супервиз допустим, то есть, вот, здесь. Мне кажется что, она может как, Супервиз работать.
Arina Mokrousova: Дискусіонний вопрос?
FANATIC Agency: Над алисой И, над дашей потому, что, по, факту у, нас все мясо собрано И здесь. Только нужно будет собирать проявление. Ну. Как, собирать проявление как, будто, бы алисты и даше понимают, Им, нужно просто ну чтобы, кто то.
Arina Mokrousova: Добре.
Arina Mokrousova: Угу?
FANATIC Agency: Их ревьюэл То. Есть это, не, знаю какая, то почасовка. От кате?
FANATIC Agency: Да. Вот?
FANATIC Agency: То есть, мне кажется это она сможет потянуть на фреле и потом если, что, вот этот вот сторител как, она, собирала для. Вот это. Вот. Текущей презентации?
Arina Mokrousova: Угу?
FANATIC Agency: Вот давайте, такой, формат с, ней завтра проговорим. Опять. Таки. Я. Думаю что. Сегодня, антон будет понимать?
FANATIC Agency: Антон запише что дала какой, нибудь, голосовой а потом, по это угор?
FANATIC Agency: Вот понимать вообще, как они настроены, они что то там выбирать, и так далее. Смысли идти дальше?
Arina Mokrousova: Ну ладно, Ну, Ми, в?
Arina Mokrousova: Інформації?
Антон Аверьянов: Я Сегодня керкюр. Него Поговорил Он запиши. Голосовое?
Антон Аверьянов: Ну Да, я, бы не она пока, не понимает, вообще. Никогда. Не работала в корпорациях что ее, ждет, какая, загруженность воют несчасть На берегу?
O!Sapiens Expert: The…
Антон Аверьянов: Говорит, что сможет новолюбная для рассчита.
Arina Mokrousova: Угу Ну коротше панова. Косметик Нам Получається?
FANATIC Agency: Да, я за себя просто записываю, чтобы завтра навстречу, То есть, то банка, то проговорить историю с супервиза, Возможно Фьючер, проф. Важно. Довести за эти две недели Здесь ответ. Надопинать. Надо будет клиента?
FANATIC Agency: Новый косметикс нужно, принять решение мы. На все мы. Просто сариной уже. Начали эту историю обсуждать и, я, запросила у этих уподрячиков, с которыми там я до этого работал, примерную, оценку. Если бы они делали этот проект, чтоб?
FANATIC Agency: У нас, хотя бы было понимание?
FANATIC Agency: У нас в целом есть алиса Которая, Ну, в, состоянии провести но алиса не, в Состоянии сделать отчет?
Антон Аверьянов: Нет?
FANATIC Agency: По такому большому скоку, работ?
FANATIC Agency: Вот.
FANATIC Agency: Короче Новая, Косметикс И Айбиэс?
Arina Mokrousova: Угу?
FANATIC Agency: По Айбис как будто у нас у нас сегодня синг. По Айбис Мы, Поймем что, мы будем делать вот. И сразу. По Айбес Скажу, у, нас же там еще как, бы алина Была В Голове которая?
Антон Аверьянов: Да, да?
FANATIC Agency: Может нам с чем помочь. Вот, мы пока ее никак не интегрировали то есть, мы Ждем вообще, а куда мы можем ее интегрировать то, здесь если. Че?
Антон Аверьянов: Да?
Антон Аверьянов: Я, бы, может, быть попробовал я, Да, сразу подключать экстрендум?
FANATIC Agency: Примим решение?
Антон Аверьянов: Мы не хотели это параллелить, но ислыкать одна.
Антон Аверьянов: Исходе, то может быть, алина. Тогда сразу включится чтобы, она просто потом подхотила?
FANATIC Agency: Ну давайте, Сегодня, тогда, поймем, что там, происходит и тогда, просто также и проговорим если что, там?
Антон Аверьянов: Да, Хорошо?
Arina Mokrousova: Ми сьогодні?
O!Sapiens Expert: Thank you, Karolina. Of course.
O!Sapiens Expert: Mmhm.
Антон Аверьянов: Я высылал, как то, в ходовский чат с сообщение алины это. Студентка На. С. Баклобриатом фете которая Яков, Партнер Работала Вот, она несколько детей назад написала что она в итоге уходит из як в?
O!Sapiens Expert: Mmm.
O!Sapiens Expert: No problem.
Антон Аверьянов: Актер, спросил если, какой то, фриланс вы решили попробовать ее выделить бюджет небольшой из айбиэс и подключить. Ее. До исследовательскую часть, в, том числе чтобы, посмотреть как, бы легков партнера сделал. Исследотельскую часть?
O!Sapiens Expert: Mmhm.
O!Sapiens Expert: Thank you, Sean.
Антон Аверьянов: Мы не хотели ее параллилить с катей чтобы она сама в понном делала чтобы ну как, бы, мы, посмотрели другой результат работы. Здесь, сейчас. На одно имеет смысл ее просто сразу подключить.
Arina Mokrousova: Короче?
Arina Mokrousova: Короче, Давайте, сегодня мы! Получается смотрим. Еще нашли, алиса, и, Даша Потому что они смотрели трендрепорт, и собранные клиентом?
Arina Mokrousova: Вот а наверно навстрече, завтра искать Наверное, мы поймем, там, какую, часть она делать. И тогда это я просто. Говорю потому что, если мы алину подключаем то, нам нужен каким то, образом работу между ними струклировать?
Arina Mokrousova: Вот, то что, ну, Не, хотелось бы выдавать одно и то, же задание и кате, и, али, то, Там, Надо, будет тогда понять что, на, какой кусок там катя забирает на себя Какой тогда мы олиня даем.
Arina Mokrousova: Если мы понимаем, уже примерно. Как будет структурирован, работаюталь?
FANATIC Agency: Ну, Я, думаю что, мы можем это сегодня на, синки, по красы обсудить что, мы хотим подключать алину необятельно. Говорить, на всех, что катя Уходит?
FANATIC Agency: Вот на тех, кто будет насинки, а там, кто там собственту колисца. Будет из тех кто, возможно, еще, не знает?
Arina Mokrousova: Алиса?
FANATIC Agency: Вот мы поймем, как катя Видит этот эту структуру и, просто поймем, вообще, что, может забрать на себя катя с учетом, что у нее есть вот две недели?
Arina Mokrousova: Угу?
FANATIC Agency: Вот и что мы можем делегировать о Лини А, потом тогда, какую, нибудь, передачу сделаем на следующей неделе погружение я просто напишу. Алине Узнаю.
Arina Mokrousova: Че?
FANATIC Agency: Я помню, что антон Говорил Что на якобе куда, то. Должна Выйти в сентябре?
FANATIC Agency: Но я, не помню?
Антон Аверьянов: Не она сказала, что ищет она сказала что ищет, Но надо уточнить не. Я. Могу написать она.
FANATIC Agency: Да? Не напишу?
FANATIC Agency: Окей, ладно, ну, Получается?
Arina Mokrousova: По проектам Получается, что все. Вот по деньгам тебя.
Arina Mokrousova: Надо понять какая, ситуация?
FANATIC Agency: По деньгам. Получается, что у нас будет выплата десятого диане и, получается что, одиннадцатого у Нас Должна быть выплата сразу кате?
FANATIC Agency: У Кате нет никаких отходных отступных то что. Ну она, по своему, желанию, увольняется у нее, будет компенсация за неотгульный. Отпуск у нее. Что то, там, до хера дней, тридцать, пять, если я. Правильно. Читаю табличку которую у, нас есть то есть?
FANATIC Agency: Вероятно, что, там сумма будет на тысячу по двести.
FANATIC Agency: Вот выплат. Вот аня, выйдет из отпуска Аня Бухгалтер в понедельник Вот. У нас не в двенадцать встреч а, Я попрошу ее она посчитает мы. Поймем?
FANATIC Agency: Ну то, есть где, то наверное, пол, лямы, нам, придется, выплатить скорее всего, может Чуть меньше вот одиннадцатого числа.
FANATIC Agency: В смысле десятого и одиннадцатого в совокупе?
Arina Mokrousova: На Диану И на качестве еще на Миллион и плюс у кате женщин?
FANATIC Agency: Не миллион?
Arina Mokrousova: Ага и пересукать. Еще процент. Будут?
FANATIC Agency: Там?
FANATIC Agency: Ну, с процентами это Такая. Же история видимо, как, с дианой Будет мы. Также. Будем договариваться заключим с ней диани. Написала, что как коллеги на выйдет из отпуска Она подготовить с ней договор. С я. Забрала у ней ее реквизиты на самый. Занятую.
O!Sapiens Expert: Mm-hmm.
FANATIC Agency: Итак, же сделаем на кате ну также? Ей У, кате, Пока, у кате прибавиться процентов у, нее там сейчас тысяч двести?
FANATIC Agency: У нее прибавиться. За ат банк.
FANATIC Agency: Вот он закроется в сентябре Вот. И там от, и, банк он, довольно большой там сумма.
FANATIC Agency: Два восемьсот?
FANATIC Agency: Вот от него. Соответственно?
FANATIC Agency: Ну. Это, Ваши, пятнадцать процентов не. Морщи?
O!Sapiens Expert: Не Нет Эточ. Понять. Тот как, бы процент мы, начисляем за ну как бы, весь, проект или только за, первую, половину. Там, чем закрывается ну. То, есть она, полностью все. Доводит?
FANATIC Agency: Не она. Она доводит. Проект. Полностью Сегодня финальная презентацию. Она, Весь, то банк, завершился мстоятельно то еще тут.
O!Sapiens Expert: Okay.
O!Sapiens Expert: На окко?
FANATIC Agency: Мы вычнем только из него тридцать пять тысяч это то. Что мы, платим фрелу за презентацию, больше У. Нас Там?
FANATIC Agency: А нет, не тридцать пять, чуть, побольше, шестьдесят, пять там, мы, еще. Платили. Этим.
O!Sapiens Expert: Угу?
FANATIC Agency: Экспертам. Но?
O!Sapiens Expert: Кей?
O!Sapiens Expert: Гуд?
O!Sapiens Expert: Тогда кто с ней обсудит по. Двох процентов?
FANATIC Agency: Ну ты Можешь. Ей, также написать что такая же, вот, система будет?
O!Sapiens Expert: Okay.
O!Sapiens Expert: It's good.
FANATIC Agency: Но в смысле, не такая, же, да ну. Что как, Бы система. Выплаты процентов будет?
O!Sapiens Expert: Не знаю?
O!Sapiens Expert: Да?
O!Sapiens Expert: Ты?
FANATIC Agency: Небольшими порциями в. Течении какого то периода исходя, из наших финансовых возможностей?
O!Sapiens Expert: Хорошо?
Антон Аверьянов: Я думаю, нормально. К этому. Десятый день?
O!Sapiens Expert: Ну. Тут, Собстно, без вариантов. Она неслась.
Антон Аверьянов: Она Никуда уходит но, да.
O!Sapiens Expert: Что ж?
O!Sapiens Expert: Полная пересменка?
FANATIC Agency: Да, я никогда выйдет из отпуска в Понедельник. Тогда все документы сделают на то, чтобы подписать все эти доки с ней и, так далее?
FANATIC Agency: Ну И, надо дальше понимать чем, мы делаем?
FANATIC Agency: По новому человеку, Потому что?
Антон Аверьянов: Ну. Надо, надо смотреть мы все одно. Собирались. Сейчас Надо просто. Ускориться, Написал Петя спросил удал. Мне. Несколько человек?
FANATIC Agency: Короче?
Антон Аверьянов: И контакта. Мне Писали что, на то там цари не обсудите походить пообщаться?
Антон Аверьянов: Кого, то быстро интегрировать?
Arina Mokrousova: Но я бы на самом деле не рассчитала, что быстро сможем квад интегрировать потому что наим долге всегда?
Arina Mokrousova: Вот То есть этот вариант. Это а вариант. Хочу нам за варят. Б. Нам Нужно. Смотреть стрелов на проект для того, чтобы сейчас выполнить обязательства перед клиентами Вас?
Arina Mokrousova: Не факт, что те фильмы, которые будут делать, какие то крусские Проекты.
Arina Mokrousova: Нужны нам в командой нам. Нужно просто сделать некоторые проект?
Антон Аверьянов: Доктослава?
Антон Аверьянов: Дэкнин?
Arina Mokrousova: Сейчас нагрузку увеличивается. На нас. С тобой Вот мы уже вместо Дианы, делаем. Воркшоп, Порталу?
Arina Mokrousova: А у меня, кроме, идянинг в, проектах еще, другие шок леверика есть магнит Который, Я супервизион, там, где здесь, сложил?
Arina Mokrousova: Новокосметик тоже. Если будет делать фри, узнать что отпряжет на меня, в той первис?
FANATIC Agency: Ну А, мы а, мы не хотим вакансию дать?
Arina Mokrousova: Выйди и зайди Нормально.
FANATIC Agency: Да?
Arina Mokrousova: Вакансию дать?
FANATIC Agency: Ну Конечно, если, мы напишем даже, у, нас есть два канала который нам сто процентов принесут леды канал, первый, это стратосфера которая, очень не любит трогать антон если антон туда напишет. Что, мы Ищем?
FANATIC Agency: Там этого стратега просто. Мне. Кажется. Здесь арина, тебя, важно, Какие, то?
FANATIC Agency: Хайлайт Чтобы, сразу отсечь хиробору всякую вот Этих вот которые просто, не, хочу работать с антоном вот я только Закончил Курсы. Я Письдеться как?
FANATIC Agency: Какой я молодец. Нам такие не нужны ну. Чтобы. Че, то, было предметно и можно сразу чтобы не писали антону сразу дать чей то, этот либо, тебя?
Arina Mokrousova: Угу?
FANATIC Agency: Чтобы тебе, сразу сыпались, Вот потому, что есть будсыпаться в антона у Нас Уское горлышко начнется?
Антон Аверьянов: Да, да, да?
FANATIC Agency: Вот мне?
FANATIC Agency: Да. Либо, мы, можем не знаю дать если мы. Дадим контакт коллягины. Просто чтобы, она, собирала это тоже. Будет, тоское горлышко Но к тебе будет постоянно ходить мне кажется. Лучно, приму, и сразу твой, контакт но от тебя, нужны кита, хайлайты, и надо через наш?
FANATIC Agency: Этот канал и через антона И, Мы, сейчас сразу себе подсыпим что нибудь?
Arina Mokrousova: Ну, Вот, я, с одной стороны понимаю, а с, Другой. Стороны.
Arina Mokrousova: А с другой стороны нам, нужен, синие?
FANATIC Agency: Угу?
Arina Mokrousova: А Синеров. Так не ищу, прочесывая это просто кучатся звонок будет. И это, проходило уже сигнал?
Arina Mokrousova: Вот А у меня работа есть, другая, которую делать. Надо Вот параллельно нанимать синера. И делать проекты. Это Жопа. Вот это работать. По двенадцать по четырнадцать часов в день я. Так Не хочу и, это просто долгий перебор. У меня. Вот. Ощущения что синера проще найти либо через рефераль не. Знаем.
Arina Mokrousova: Вот, например, час мы запросили антон. Запросил упить ее?
Arina Mokrousova: Контакт. Надо познакомиться с этими людьми Наверно, Я бы сходил не. Знаю канем дудаева все таки стигнул, Вот Надо. Выдергивать людей, которых конкретно с ними выходить на контакт и. Там уже?
Arina Mokrousova: Разговорят, так будет быстрее. Ну. Или по крайней мире начаться этих людей може сейчас если, открыть, просто антон сейчас. Напишет.
Антон Аверьянов: Адатон?
Arina Mokrousova: Это, Мы получим большое количество обращений и. У меня просто весь день будет выгляди все. Неделю что я, только, с ними созваниюсь?
Arina Mokrousova: Из них много будет ну типа. Не?
Arina Mokrousova: Нерелевантных. С Чего. Бы мы не написали вакансии?
FANATIC Agency: А У Пети мы. Запрашивали антон с Каким то, Конкретным запросом что нам. Нужен. Синиор?
Антон Аверьянов: Да, Да, я я запросил на Синера, но я так глянул, на ребят которых, он, высло я не. Уверен что они синьорные?
O!Sapiens Expert: Мне. Ну. Крепкий. Мидл это, Тоже, Хорошо?
Arina Mokrousova: Да, это, наверное, даже тут лучшие. На соглашительном насадному, что даже, наверное, лучше типа, человек, с потенциалом какому то росту?
Arina Mokrousova: Ну другой, вопрос что, я бы наверное, сразу, так, сказала что, мы мне не нравится этот смена типа пересменка в, смысле.
Arina Mokrousova: Назвать это знайте. Потому, что, то выблюдко бы то, мы одних людей на других меняем вот?
Arina Mokrousova: Это Будто не так но, короче, что я хочу сказать что скорее, я обставила, сейчас сдачу найти человека на место Дианы. Вот этот синий, скорее, человек на место Дианы чем на место Кати.
Arina Mokrousova: Потому, что человек на Место Кати, мы долго будем искать?
Arina Mokrousova: Если мы хотим с теми же компетенциями?
O!Sapiens Expert: Что жде.
O!Sapiens Expert: Ну Тоже Вопрос да. В, берег у. Нас есть там понимание того куда мы, движемся а вторых но, тут.
O!Sapiens Expert: Я не уверен, что тут стоит рассуждать категориями там замены диани и кати скорее понимания. Того Какие компетенции, нужны?
Arina Mokrousova: Так этому. На прошлой встречу же обсудились над?
O!Sapiens Expert: Да, но?
Arina Mokrousova: Мы обсудили, что, если нового, мы открываем, то мы будем искать?
O!Sapiens Expert: На прошлой встречи. Не Блакать?
O!Sapiens Expert: Кинобла?
Arina Mokrousova: Да, не какая разница не. В это. Я не про это говорю. Я. Говорю, про то, что мы в прошлый раз обсуждали. Мы же знаем что, где, она уходит, и, говорили, что, нужно, кого то искать и, я как, раз. Мы с антоном разговаривали, типа, Какой профиль человека и мы поняли, что мы ищем, скорее классического бронстратега но. Что то, все одно пока, наш. Кэш флоу?
Антон Аверьянов: Да, да, да?
Arina Mokrousova: Вот типа, мы на этом деньги зарабатывали, и Как бы мы думали пред этом, что катя типа будет с нами Вот теперь, как бы, катя тоже уходит но, я говорю про то что, скорее, вакансию опубликовать и Человека сейчас искать нужно это, вот классический бронстратек типа. Условно, Аля Диана Просто. Катю. Мы долго. Будет. Искать лучшее?
Антон Аверьянов: Да?
Антон Аверьянов: Ну, Да, я, согласен и, тогда надо искать просто. Изначально то. Неуслоб на замену катя а Этот Функционал человека наверно больше всеследовательским бекграундом. Лич. Он Количественные. Методы. От Него не. Так важно. Чтобы он мог, пронес стратегию, сам собрать и так далее?
Arina Mokrousova: Угу?
Антон Аверьянов: Просто кате то, и, другое вы в себе совмещала но если. Мы?
Антон Аверьянов: Мы с фокусируемся больше на хорошем исследователя.
Антон Аверьянов: Думающем, умеющем считать, то такие такие есть?
O!Sapiens Expert: Ну давайте. Поймем, Че, Нам, педи, хватит, или, нам, начто. Еще, Нужно?
Arina Mokrousova: Короче?
Антон Аверьянов: Да, я сейчас перешлю. Аренда К. Доти Надо глянуть. Может, Ты, Их, Знаешь, я никого не знаю из Тех Кого написал, и мы тогда спишемся с тобой. Решим. Что, то?
Arina Mokrousova: Да Давай он?
Arina Mokrousova: Антона?
Arina Mokrousova: Угу?
Arina Mokrousova: Да, И мы решили что, мы на, следующей неделе мы же. Еще двадцатого созванивали с вами говорили что. Типа надо, там закрыть некоторые вопрос. Вот Слово и, мы завтра там созваниемся один. Следующей. Неделе с тридцать первого там быть начнем уже?
Антон Аверьянов: Да?
Arina Mokrousova: С наймом. Думать?
Arina Mokrousova: Ну давайте По, Крайней мере, тогда созвонимся, с, петинами и я напишу, ане будаевой?
Arina Mokrousova: Сигнал?
FANATIC Agency: Ну. Давай, еще подумаем кто, может быть у? Нас еще остался из сигналовских хороших?
Arina Mokrousova: Нет. Уже всех же?
Arina Mokrousova: Кто в б, кто в саду?
FANATIC Agency: Сет?
O!Sapiens Expert: Друг?
Arina Mokrousova: Ну Как бы я не хочу допустим писать не знаю. Маше. И фильмы. Она работает уже. В команде саши летнего ну Типа, зачем, Мне буду забирать стратегу вот или? Там Рите стурис она Работает тудашь Кравцовой. На. Хира мне портнится Отношения С кравцовой Из.
FANATIC Agency: Ага?
Arina Mokrousova: С.
Arina Mokrousova: Следнего?
FANATIC Agency: Я могу написать рите, Мне, все Равно на отношениях с дашей?
Arina Mokrousova: Теплофик, Да?
Arina Mokrousova: Не ну блин ты понимаешь, же. Что они, потом все ко мне придут вот?
Arina Mokrousova: Все ка. Мне, предскажете че?
Arina Mokrousova: Охуела?
FANATIC Agency: Я так не думаю арин. Я, так и, не думаю это. Как, бы?
Arina Mokrousova: Звезду, поймала?
Arina Mokrousova: Я уберена, что летнеев Мне напишет вот. Твоя уверена?
O!Sapiens Expert: Фильмы?
O!Sapiens Expert: Ты, просто прикинешься валенком и скажешь что, ты, ничего не знаешь?
FANATIC Agency: Не. Не. Я. Не.
FANATIC Agency: Я не про летнего я прориту?
Arina Mokrousova: Ага конечно?
FANATIC Agency: Вот ну. Как, бы но, здесь я, не хочу делать так чтоб, тебе услуга мне. Комфортно было.
Arina Mokrousova: Нет, А я просто ну знаю же что урита, там, тоже ей уже сделали трек и у нее, там она на синее. Расс идет у нее. Там тоже. Есть Программа развития. Он. То, Есть как, бы?
Arina Mokrousova: Я понимаю, что это просто?
Arina Mokrousova: Уже сейчас. Типа. Ну. И Это, начнется торг мы Будем. Переманивать деньгами короче?
O!Sapiens Expert: Мы?
Arina Mokrousova: Это целая операция, которая неизбежная, приведет к тому, что Кравцова придет ко мне, и скаже что, ты, охудела?
Антон Аверьянов: Рик?
O!Sapiens Expert: Ну, окей?
O!Sapiens Expert: Не вариант?
O!Sapiens Expert: Хорошо?
Антон Аверьянов: Но тоже еще говорила что, напомим больше на одну такую классическую коммуникационную работу заточенную?
Arina Mokrousova: Ну. Да, Вот, она, по этому в саду и работает но она. Не то. Что знаешь как, заточена она, просто туда, пошла ей. Там. Интересно?
Arina Mokrousova: Она была, то плюс минус такая, же, по компетенциям, как Воо?
FANATIC Agency: Ладно ну. Тогда Ну, Давай, Будаевой, да Напишем, что, Тоже?
Антон Аверьянов: Ладно, давайте. Посмотрим, Че, Петя, Выслал, или Дальше Давно?
O!Sapiens Expert: А может, все. Же, есть смысл кинуть вообщи, какой то наш то, же канал?
O!Sapiens Expert: Собрать?
O!Sapiens Expert: Вопрос, что ждать?
Антон Аверьянов: Да, мотор?
Антон Аверьянов: Ну От мы, только что поговорили что, скорее все будет не бедлы не синера откликаться и сейчас, пройдем по горячем потом, Если там ничего не будет тогда уже клично накидать?
O!Sapiens Expert: Да, не, но там просто это в больших количествах, то можно через ишку прогнать. Да начленись.
O!Sapiens Expert: Мне более интересное?
Arina Mokrousova: Прогнать через Яишку. Что? Резюме?
O!Sapiens Expert: Ну, да?
Arina Mokrousova: Да, это. Безсмысленно Там общаться нагда. Надо в. Любом случае ставить встречу?
Антон Аверьянов: Кто там же общаться надо?
O!Sapiens Expert: Да, не понятно, что это, надо. Просто Я хотел бы совсем как, это непрофильных. Людей сеч.
O!Sapiens Expert: Фильтровать базово?
O!Sapiens Expert: Посмотри здесь. Вам Кажется что, мы сейчас с первого наберем окей просто, я, думаю, скречить, наперед и, если мы с Первого Никого не соберем то нам, это удлиник процесс?
O!Sapiens Expert: Как мы там будем?
FANATIC Agency: Будем фрелами пока, перебиваться?
FANATIC Agency: Троякный?
Arina Mokrousova: Еще можем проверить почту свою. Нам. Там люди писали как, там в прошлом году с нет?
FANATIC Agency: Там писали я. Же все я. Читаю все. Письма там. Нет Ничего такого сверхъестественного что стоило бы, внимание?
Arina Mokrousova: А в прошлом году?
FANATIC Agency: Ну В, прошлом году я не, знаю, в прошлом году у, меня нет доступа?
O!Sapiens Expert: Мы?
O!Sapiens Expert: И в кого нет. Доступа?
FANATIC Agency: Играет Ли он остался?
FANATIC Agency: Ты, же гугл бы?
FANATIC Agency: Там все?
FANATIC Agency: Проималось?
O!Sapiens Expert: Давай поймем, какие то хотя бы Даты когда мы там пройдем по тем, кого мы получили, от петели. Если там ничего то?
Arina Mokrousova: На Следующей неделе мы. С антоном договоре?
Антон Аверьянов: На следующей неделе в. Следующей. Неделе есть время?
O!Sapiens Expert: Следующий, четверг. Мы Такие Типа Окей меняем подход?
FANATIC Agency: Ну давайте ну К Следующему, Четвергу, Поймем, поймем, что у нас. Есть, но, то есть я, думаю, что мы, как, бы успеем там с Ани Будаевой, Поговорить.
FANATIC Agency: Посмотреть. Что прислал петя?
O!Sapiens Expert: Ты?
FANATIC Agency: И примем. Есть Ли там что, то?
FANATIC Agency: Ну? С, кем стоит разговаривать?
FANATIC Agency: Если нет, тогда план Б.
O!Sapiens Expert: Угу?
O!Sapiens Expert: Гуд?
FANATIC Agency: А я Пойму. По Деньгам, счетам. У нас. Тогда?
Arina Mokrousova: Антон, У. Тебя сегодня еще с дианой какая, то стрелка?
Антон Аверьянов: Мы перенесли ее на завтра она. Со все никуда не?
Arina Mokrousova: План, Хорошо?
O!Sapiens Expert: Да?
Arina Mokrousova: Ну? У, вас такое у? Тебя?
Arina Mokrousova: Экс Интервью?
Антон Аверьянов: Потом то продам. Датом. Просто. Да?
O!Sapiens Expert: Чем бросны?
Антон Аверьянов: Да, просто. Она хотела поговорить?
O!Sapiens Expert: Ну, Надо, Все Равно, тогда сделать, экзит интервью и с дианой и катей если это Встреча. У Тебя уже запланирована то я бы предложил ее структурировать тогда, Так?
Антон Аверьянов: Она не. Мы договорили, что мы договорили, что оно неформальное Но я на Эверто, Ниче. То, спрошу, но?
O!Sapiens Expert: Неформаль?
O!Sapiens Expert: Но тогда все равно сделать?
Антон Аверьянов: Ну, Да, Точно, мне?
O!Sapiens Expert: Ки. Давайте. Я. Не, напишу?
O!Sapiens Expert: Тансарова?
FANATIC Agency: Я просто не знаю чего они, скажут, нового на экзитном первю что Мы Еще Не. Знаем, Не слышали на командных сфотку?
O!Sapiens Expert: Здесь.
FANATIC Agency: За последнее время. Но если это чистая формальность, то?
O!Sapiens Expert: Это не чистая формально. Здесь есть несколько аспектов, как бы с одной стороны да. Несли. Формальность с другой страны это, но может, там будет что то новое, или, в любом случае, там лишний раз зафиксировать это тоже может, быть полезно?
O!Sapiens Expert: В остальном. Это ну. Свого, рода закрытие. Такого процесса найма взаимодействия и. Все же пять лет это срок.
O!Sapiens Expert: Какие бы ни были этом отношения там, чего, не происходило это просто, Часть не знаю?
O!Sapiens Expert: Ритуал. Взаим. Это так день. Вважения?
O!Sapiens Expert: Создать пространство человеку, чтобы поделиться своими эмоциями, мыслями, приживаниями?
O!Sapiens Expert: Важно?
Arina Mokrousova: Ну. Если, У тебя есть запрос на то чтобы, проводить эту психологическую практику то, в принципи без, проблем а так Я оно. Уже закрыла Все?
Arina Mokrousova: Психологически уже отпустила, но уже ниху я не делают последнюю, неделю даже, те обязательства которая, должна, выполнять она их. Не. Выполняют, Поэтому появи мне психологические двери, у него закрыты.
FANATIC Agency: Диана. Максимально сепарировалась сразу ж мт?
FANATIC Agency: До Свидулья, Ребята?
FANATIC Agency: Дальше. Сами, как нибудь?
O!Sapiens Expert: Скачик, супроизвест?
FANATIC Agency: Сант, Антоно?
Антон Аверьянов: Выходную?
Антон Аверьянов: Но мне надо будет только заборифовать. Я Их никогда не проводил все. Не. Знаю в чем, там квались?
Антон Аверьянов: Дело, какой то гает сможет?
O!Sapiens Expert: Угу?
O!Sapiens Expert: Да?
O!Sapiens Expert: Да. Да. Я могу скинуть?
FANATIC Agency: Ладно. Тогда, Я запишу на следующий четверг да что У нас, Тогда, мы, промежуточный чек делаем че. Вообще происходит с наймом и откуда дальше? Мы это?
Антон Аверьянов: Окей. Окей. Давайте. Дальше, тем?
FANATIC Agency: Идем бежим?
FANATIC Agency: Так?
FANATIC Agency: Еще У нас. Есть арин С Тобой вопрос. По Маркетингу который ты хотел, поднять и у меня, Есть Вопрос по встрече. Вот в этом в банке. Санкт Петербурга Антон?
FANATIC Agency: Че Мы. Вообще как, бы сейчас вот, мы подойдем сегодня в тендер т банка я. Надеюсь. Мы, Разберемся с этим с?
FANATIC Agency: Как облиять с полюсом с этим?
Антон Аверьянов: Золото, Полюс?
FANATIC Agency: Да. Вот?
FANATIC Agency: И?
FANATIC Agency: Я могу име начать заниматься на следующей неделе? Потому, Что то с седьмого числа я в отпуске на две недели то если, на следующей неделе финальное перед отпуском?
Антон Аверьянов: Окей. Окей?
FANATIC Agency: Вот.
FANATIC Agency: Че там, вообще алина что то, должна, прислать, или кто, то или, у, нас, что то есть?
Антон Аверьянов: Нет, нет, нет, нет, нет, там, все понятно. Они Ждут от нас сейчас шнуков. Но нам надо просто сделать офер?
Антон Аверьянов: В чем там, какая там ситуация?
Антон Аверьянов: Внешние брыды банковской безумносильно меняются. Сейчас его очень сильно поменяют. Введение цифрового рубля?
Антон Аверьянов: Там. Я не знаю на, сколько вы сбирались с тем что, это такое но, там ключевое к чему. Придет цифровый рубль?
Антон Аверьянов: К тому, что у тебя счет будет открыт не в банке. А счет, будет открыт В Цб, А Банке просто Дают доступ к этому счету. То еще тебя будет условно один кошелек, который будет называться цифровой рубль и, он, будет у тебя доступен во всех твоих банковских приложениях?
Антон Аверьянов: В Сбере, в альфе, Там В, Т, банке и. Так, далее единный кошелек сквозной через. Все. Банки. Потому что деньги в цб И многие. Банки из второго эшелона прогнозируют что, из за то что, в них леновые продукты цифровой то их клиентов уйдут?
Антон Аверьянов: В топовые банке, тому, что сейчас вообще нету, никакого?
Антон Аверьянов: Барьеры. Для этого перехода. Эти единый кошелек и, ты доступ него. Получаешь в любом банке поэтому то, банку выбираешь просто по формату того, что он удобный. Удобное, приложение офис, и так далее?
Антон Аверьянов: Соответить с этом?
Антон Аверьянов: Пспб?
Антон Аверьянов: Банк. Санкт Петербург Он Собирается. Перестраиваться?
Антон Аверьянов: Они хотят больше. Работать. С высоходоходной аудиторией, которые не так важны какие. То Цифровые сервисы развивать свою офлайн сеть они. Сделали Флагмарский офис в Москве. У них есть Несколько. Флагманов в санкт петербурге?
Антон Аверьянов: И так далее. Они хотят стать больше. Ну. Прям. Проториентированными?
Антон Аверьянов: Чтобы они давали, какой то единый опыты. В офлайне, в коммуникации, и, так далее в, чем Особенность они сначально вообще об этом никогда не задумывались, потому что на Семьдесят процентов. Корпоративный банк?
Антон Аверьянов: И семьдесят процентов. Всегрочки внеходется бетубе клиенту поэтому, бедусишня когда они. Были, так общем?
Антон Аверьянов: Только поскольку у них даже нету отдела маркетинга у них нету, маркетологов у них маркетингов ролит как руководитель. Разночного блока Но он Финансист и для него маркетинг это. Выбрать дизайн. Плаката. И вот я говорил?
Антон Аверьянов: Первый заместитель председателя Правления На общести посел тот Павел?
Антон Аверьянов: Нормальный, обменяемый дядька. И Он говорит что, для нас маркетинг своятся. К Тому что мы, в фотографии на постер выбираем, Но вот, сейчас не хотят, что это менять, и перестаивать?
Антон Аверьянов: Они?
Антон Аверьянов: Фоном. Через кого то из рекрутеров ищут себе, Семо и параллельно, они хотя сделать следующее у, них есть, как бы, платформа?
Антон Аверьянов: Она, но особо неформализована, но они себя воспринимают, как такой, самый культурный, банк, что они с культурной столицей Они всегда не навязывают. У них такая. Классическая питерская культура там. За достолевского Поговорить. И все. Такое?
Антон Аверьянов: И они хотят?
Антон Аверьянов: Они хотят?
Антон Аверьянов: Чтобы этой культуры мы помогли пропитать их компанию то есть изначально не видит проект следующий но. Или. Там, как я с ними обслуживал. Навстрече. Мы. Первым. Этапом соберем все что у, них, есть в платформа проведем интервью?
Антон Аверьянов: С топами. Повторно соберем это все в платформу. Она, ну, кабы. У, Них, сама. Ощущения из себя тарынки есть нам надо. Это все просто в слайды превратить.
Антон Аверьянов: И дальше. Мы сделаем серию рабочих сесей с их, сотрудниками разных отделов?
Антон Аверьянов: Тому, что они говорят что, у нас сейчас вообще нету понимания того как, молки сестроем как. Мы. Обслуживаем как, У нас. Поддержка работает, Как у нас цифровой продукт делается? Это все каждый сам себя, хозяин, Они хотят, это все попробовать.
Антон Аверьянов: Развернуть вокруг какого, то единого опыта весь час. По большому. Счету проект это интервью. Описание Платформы. И серии стратесий с разными имплементационных С Разными?
Антон Аверьянов: Отделами компании?
Антон Аверьянов: Дальше. Не уже там. Сами когда выйдет этот седьмо начнут. Раскатывать это на комстрат и, так далее сейчас. Мы этим не паримся. Сейчас у нас. Три?
Антон Аверьянов: И этапах можно быстро.
Антон Аверьянов: Делать?
FANATIC Agency: Наверно, нужно. У алина Запросить Во первого количества вообще. Интервью кто эти. Топа да?
Антон Аверьянов: Он говорил нас, Да Да, он, говорил, у Нас, восемь человек. В функциональных линиях и вот этот дятелько я. Вам был посылал там в чат который, был ну с мажоритарий?
FANATIC Agency: Которые нам важны?
FANATIC Agency: Угу?
Антон Аверьянов: Текущий сериал, сказал, что его, тоже надо. Включить. Он ну возрастной. Он. Не Совсем понимает, Про бренд но он понимает про культуру компании, потому что он ее создал?
Антон Аверьянов: И он Скорее даст лучше понимания того кто, они внутри тож девять интервью давай. Посчитаем это они. Проговорили?
FANATIC Agency: Угу?
FANATIC Agency: И собираем просто платформу, как условно, сделали свет принимательским брендом, типа, вижен их, как то переплавляем?
Антон Аверьянов: Там есть. Какие?
Антон Аверьянов: Да, да?
Антон Аверьянов: Да, да, да. Здесь Больше фактуры У них тут есть какие. То Исследования бхт у них они проводили. Фокус группы глубинники. Тось, это просто повторять. Не надо.
FANATIC Agency: Ага?
Антон Аверьянов: У них ключевое и глобальное что они, себя Внутри самоосознают как вот Этот Культурный банк.
Антон Аверьянов: И они туда подсознательно копают там проблема. В. Том. Что это нетопозиционированная, история а там есть, Очень большой гэп между тем, как менеджмент себя ощущают, они. Все вырубнено Они Говорят там мы. Давно, для, себя эти смыслы сформулировали?
Антон Аверьянов: Но дальше на уровне имплементации это. Все не живет там просто. Нету. Ни отдела маркетинга ни отдела которые забрат отпечают чтобы, это все направить?
Антон Аверьянов: Вот так. Надо подлечить.
FANATIC Agency: Достоевского отдела продаж. Те не могут понять это, достоевский. Или, может, быть тургенев или, еще, кто то, несчитывает, да такая у них это. Самая идентификация там летить.
Антон Аверьянов: Примерно. Да, да, да, да. Да примертно?
FANATIC Agency: А вот эти вот отделы, с которыми мы, эти имплементационные воркшопы будем, проводить тоже Есть понимание что, это за отделы?
Антон Аверьянов: Они ждут это от нас но, было желание начаться всех фронтов?
Антон Аверьянов: Это можно будет туалетный потом до уточнить я бы Отдела. Четыре точно взял.
Антон Аверьянов: Это?
Arina Mokrousova: Но вот у меня вопрос, был, как раз жаня его предосхятила если, они хотят развивать работу с высокодоходной аудитории битуси соответственно, у них должен появиться отдел которого, видимо, Сейчас, пока, в структуре нет?
Антон Аверьянов: Это есть. У них как, раз я даже был вот но, они довольно большие по Размеру у. Них. Там Три отдельных здания стоят их?
Антон Аверьянов: И я был в этом с двадцать пятого этажа отделем. Начинаются отделы, которые обслуживают Вип. Клиентов есть, Опять же они, они умеют работать с этим?
Антон Аверьянов: У. Них я. Был вообще на этаже двадцать седьмом он весь просто. Для встречи с клиентами с випами и, там, такая панорама На Триста шестьдесят?
Антон Аверьянов: У них есть это. У. Них. Это недопозиционированое и у них, там нету общих, принципов того как бренд разворачивает то, есть, Это просто, такой Хороший сервис?
Антон Аверьянов: Для хайнетов ультра хайнетов?
Arina Mokrousova: Ну. То, есть короче, Нам, нужны, люди которые сбыт, все работают люди которые. Бит, убий работают?
Антон Аверьянов: Да, так?
Антон Аверьянов: Да, да, люди, Сбетуфи, люди с битуби, отдельные, ребятка, которые пили, цифровой продукт они. Там. Взяли Какого то, директора паи а не кучу и, каких он делают?
Arina Mokrousova: В Отель Воркшопа?
Антон Аверьянов: Светловой. Продукты?
FANATIC Agency: Ну. Окей, Хорошо, Давайте, я, прикину. Просто ну. Примерно?
FANATIC Agency: И А. Эти, воркшоп, это скорее все. Все. Офлайн.
FANATIC Agency: По ходу дела да.
Антон Аверьянов: Думаешь, туда да, там важно, попитать, но да, думаешь, туда?
FANATIC Agency: Ну. Хорошо, то. Есть интервью. Я, думаю можно, в теории и, взуме провести ничего критичного а вот воркшопы, Надо Учитывать. Наверное офлайн?
Антон Аверьянов: Сто, процентов?
FANATIC Agency: Ладно. Хорошо, ну. Я примерно. Чету. Соберу, тогда на следующей Неделе. Вам покажу с ариной и потом тогда Финализирую?
FANATIC Agency: Окей, По, Ним, понятно?
Антон Аверьянов: Вот.
Антон Аверьянов: Что то хотели затратить?
FANATIC Agency: Маркетинг. Хотел. Бы еще завтра?
Arina Mokrousova: А я забыла, А Скажите вам, мешают, руки посторонному свои?
FANATIC Agency: Нет, мы не слышим, ничем?
Антон Аверьянов: Нет, мы не слышал?
O!Sapiens Expert: Норм?
Arina Mokrousova: Про маркетинг у. Меня два вопроса первый это. Помните. Мы, С, вами, с юлей Встречались. И Рассказывали Ей Ну про эту новую, бизнес модель.
Arina Mokrousova: И, соответственно, она там собирала комстрат, там такой услобный под эту. Новую. Бизнес модель?
Arina Mokrousova: Вот у меня. Вопрос. Это было, кажется, месяца, три назад?
Arina Mokrousova: Есть Какие то чикпоинты вот, у, нас поменялся комстрат?
Arina Mokrousova: Что то поменялось в показателях вообще. Не знаю мы это как, то, тречем, или, нет?
Антон Аверьянов: Нет, на собачок. Это?
Антон Аверьянов: Ну. Я, Думаю что, нам, надо постановить с юлии встретиться На Первую, очередь мне или вырадить. Слей поговорить здесь?
Arina Mokrousova: Вот, я тут. Хотела спросить типа, не, до конца понимаю. Типа маркетинг в чьей как, В зоне, влияния?
Arina Mokrousova: То, что она типа, распределенная функция. Вот со всеми работаю Но я. Вот, типа не понимаю кто из нас ее типа ну третю какие. То вот эти промежуточные симки назначают?
Arina Mokrousova: Вот Потом, что мы в четвером месте с юлей. Не. Встречаемся, в пятером не Встречаемся, и вот. Как быть понимаете, это кабуть Это как, это? Слепое Короче Пятно, какое, то?
FANATIC Agency: Угу?
Антон Аверьянов: Ну. Да, Да?
FANATIC Agency: Но вообще, она влад изначально же была как будто под тобой вот. В Структуре Если, Да. Но, просто у вас перестали. Быть Какие то эти взаимодействия коммуникации она. Просто сейчас ушла в стратосферу юля сама по. Себе, да?
O!Sapiens Expert: Изначально, Когда?
O!Sapiens Expert: Она пришла, было на как бы вместе С антоном Другое. Дело что, впоследствии выяснилось что, все же антона Больше Надо вывлекаться Потому что, когда я с ней доделывал, сайт то потом антон Пришел И Сказал что ему там, чем не нравилось она, было, переделать?
O!Sapiens Expert: Но мы, это концептуально, так и не обсудили. И оно, так, и повисла?
O!Sapiens Expert: Недавно. Сям?
O!Sapiens Expert: Но за чего текущие? Ситуации микросологичена то, он, конечно?
Arina Mokrousova: Ну, как?
Антон Аверьянов: Ну, Ну, Да, Да, тогда?
O!Sapiens Expert: Давать водное?
Arina Mokrousova: Нуди?
Антон Аверьянов: Я, тогда спешу, с нем и договоримся, что мы просто кругим после?
Антон Аверьянов: Понедельничных синков. Оставаться С ней на блок маркетингу?
Arina Mokrousova: Ну, И второй вопрос. По маркетингу это стеллом Его Не Знаю как это сказать конфигурацию, что ли я короче. Проще, Скажу чем, мне беспокоит меня беспокоить Что мы. Не делаем ничего для, расширения воронки вот.
Arina Mokrousova: Сейчас, то есть, как бы?
Arina Mokrousova: У нас. Есть Телеграм, канал?
Arina Mokrousova: Но это не тот инструмент, который обезпечивает расширение ворон. Ну типа. Новых, людей не приводят, так коммуникация о практической. Стеме?
Arina Mokrousova: Практически всегда. Это коммуникация системе кто. Тебя в? Этом телеграм канале есть вот.
Arina Mokrousova: И у нас есть проведжки. Все инструменты, которые на это направлены. Это все инструменты с привлечением спецов?
Arina Mokrousova: Вот типа вебинар. Не Знаю что нибудь еще такое, и как, бы ну классическая проблема. Любого. Агентства. Это когда спецы делают, проект у них нет времени делать вебинары или, еще какие то вещи которые влияют на привлечение грудов?
Arina Mokrousova: И как бы это часть просто?
Arina Mokrousova: Отсекает?
Arina Mokrousova: Узнать час. Такая ситуация?
O!Sapiens Expert: Помощью публикации. На Составе Но он. Не. Знаю насколько они, конечно, способствуют?
Arina Mokrousova: Но это, вот все. Работа с контентом. Да они, как будто опосредованы влияют но, как, бы вообще по факту. Состав не является местом, откуда агентство получают леды?
Arina Mokrousova: Вот это просто Там. Где?
Arina Mokrousova: Все читают и сроту друг друга. В комментах?
Arina Mokrousova: Вот это больше. Репутационная, какая, то история, что у агентство есть какой, то блок на составе или о нем что, то публикуют на сайте. Состав?
Arina Mokrousova: Вот. То есть?
Arina Mokrousova: Типа. Леды приходят?
Arina Mokrousova: Либо вот из этих рейтингах. Но, Мы про это говорили с вами что мы, это не участвуем потому что у нас такая типа философский такой. Взгляд на это либо инстаграм линкидын и какие, то, другие ну, в этой, площадке, где, как бы, можно, либо запускать продвижение, либо, каким то образом типа разговаривать, коммуницировать?
Arina Mokrousova: С новой аудитории?
Arina Mokrousova: Вот.
O!Sapiens Expert: С Инстаграмма. Мы Нище не делали и, мы его помню. Не рассматривали слинген. Мыть, пол месяца два, пытаемся восстановить доступ вроде там, на финишный прямой, но пока не востановлено.
Arina Mokrousova: В каком смысле пытает?
Антон Аверьянов: Арендовай, может. Быть у, тебя?
Антон Аверьянов: Нов?
O!Sapiens Expert: В каком смысле, доступ? Но там У Антона Потерялся доступ и, мы в этом упирались как, бутылочное, горлышко?
Arina Mokrousova: Да, да?
Антон Аверьянов: Нет, нет, нет, нет?
Антон Аверьянов: Нетла, там, уже не та сипелся ну после. То, о, чем, ты, говоришь, было решено два месяца, Назад?
O!Sapiens Expert: Но, в смысле, нет?
O!Sapiens Expert: Отчерам?
O!Sapiens Expert: Нет, но доступа до ктой стране? Соревно? Нет?
Антон Аверьянов: Сейчас Лемки. Дын. Заблокиру?
Антон Аверьянов: Есть. Сейчас. Линкидын. Заблокировал Страницу из за того, что заходили, в нее из испании они Увидели, там дорушение в общем. Чего. То?
Антон Аверьянов: Это не восстановление пароля. Пароль? Мы восстановили давно. Ли, я его дал не, юлим?
O!Sapiens Expert: Я не горю про пароль и горю. Про достоков.
Антон Аверьянов: Если не просто блокнули аккаунт?
Антон Аверьянов: Счастливы блокнули аккаунт потому, Что я с него заходил другой. Человек?
O!Sapiens Expert: Герой. Вечерин в процессе?
Arina Mokrousova: Ага?
Arina Mokrousova: А другой. Мы не можем сделать?
Arina Mokrousova: Саут?
Антон Аверьянов: Ну. Там, и, там просто у. Меня аккаунт много лет?
Антон Аверьянов: Мы сейчас этим занимаемся?
O!Sapiens Expert: Лин. Не Дает возможности сдавать два аккаунта для одного человека?
Антон Аверьянов: Я Дал леня Все, Доступа свои от, имейлов и Она, с Юлией, напри?
Arina Mokrousova: Угу?
Arina Mokrousova: Ну, Короче, Понимаете.
O!Sapiens Expert: Я отделись утра, проверял пока, она. Мне ниче не ответила?
Arina Mokrousova: Короче понимаете, про, что я говорю первые первый моменты то что маркетинг у. Нас был не связанный с вами не как с бизнесценами. Вот мы его связали там. Несколько месяцев назад, это надо треть. Вот и корректировать, как было бы, класно, если бы юля как бы сама, про это помнила, и кто то, из нас про это помню, у Нас было?
O!Sapiens Expert: Угу?
Arina Mokrousova: Кото пространство Где мы? Это обсуждаем, потому что маркетинг это, такая же полноценная. Функция Ей требуется. Такое же Внимание по этому вопросу, как бы нужно. Ну. Должны, быть какие. То майлстоуны назначные встречи это? Первое А второе Это, то Что Ну нельзя отсекать инструменты ли дегенерации?
Arina Mokrousova: Тогда, когда у тебя заняты, спецы, и они не могут продолжать делать вебинары. Это сжимает как бы?
Arina Mokrousova: Просто весь инструментарий маркетинга понимаете вот.
Arina Mokrousova: Да, это самое простое, как бы интуитивное. Вот у нас есть контент. У Нас есть эксперты, нужно делать, вебинары, мы будем их публиковать к. Нам будут приходить леды конструкция рабочая мы. На, новый, косметик, это, выглядим видимо Но Как Бы суть, в, том, что в каждом агентстве знают что она не, работает круглый год потому. Что. Ну блин?
Arina Mokrousova: Люди продаю. Ну как. Быть часы. Экспертов Продаются клиентам и, могут они делать по вебинару каждый. Месяц?
Arina Mokrousova: А просто создавать, опубликовать контент. Это, как бы не привлечет льдоф?
Антон Аверьянов: Да, согласен. Давай, давай?
Антон Аверьянов: Давай, с юлией Останемся. В понедельник?
O!Sapiens Expert: Надо понимать, что мы все ж еще исходили из ограниченности. В Инвестициях. Маркетинг, Последние. Месяцы?
Arina Mokrousova: Да, в бюджете, Но я не говорю про то что, нужно запускать рекламную компанию вот?
Arina Mokrousova: То есть, я имею, веду, что, смотри, например, публикация, какого, то кейса, или, ну, статьи, на составе это репутационный больший. Эффект вот, а, например, публикация, того же самого в инсте или в ринки дыне Это потенциальная. Лида. Генерация.
Arina Mokrousova: Вот.
Arina Mokrousova: Просто. Мы с этим не работаем. Нам. Это аукнется, как бы ну рано и понятно. Что сейчас, фанатик Получает леды от антона И. Вот Антон сделал, Пост стартосфере и у, нас пять предпринимательских проектов но маркетинг как. Бы у, него, должны быть инструменты где он?
Антон Аверьянов: Да?
Arina Mokrousova: Ну, Как, бы занимается этими инструментами либо генерации?
O!Sapiens Expert: Да, все, так?
Антон Аверьянов: Давайте. На Арендовай предложим юлю в понедельник?
Антон Аверьянов: Остаться после качапа если, де Там есть время?
Антон Аверьянов: Посмотрим, что то, сейчас в плане, и но под. Потом, я возмог подконтроливать?
Arina Mokrousova: Но у нас. Вот есть встреча. Кстате с женю, да где мы, как раз там, чут, обсуждаем. Кат, следующий, квартал но мы там обсуждаем, По моему женить. Встреча. По тем по контенту да у. Нас Стоит?
FANATIC Agency: Ну. У, нас да. У. Нас единственная встреча по маркетингу когда мы, приходим и, накидываем юли свои идеи по тому че, нам вообще сделать по контенту это как, бы в, этом нет ничего страшного понятно что она там, не может знать всего что происходит. На проект?
Arina Mokrousova: На Следующей неделе?
FANATIC Agency: Но а факт, в том что, мы действительно?
FANATIC Agency: Только на этом, и держимся больше у. Нас нет ни. Херра. Да Она У, Нас, Стоит, в понедельник в пять?
Антон Аверьянов: Когда это?
Arina Mokrousova: Это тридцать Первое сейчас. Я. Проверяю Джоу Антона в Это время?
FANATIC Agency: Него, свободно?
Антон Аверьянов: Да я, могу?
Arina Mokrousova: Помощно. Можно просто антон. Туда. Добавить и там, у, нас целый. Час. И, как, то можно после этого. Сразу?
Антон Аверьянов: Размагала?
Антон Аверьянов: Давайте?
FANATIC Agency: Часи. Напишу Юли Я, Юли, Напишу Дашь?
Arina Mokrousova: Жен? А. Можешь написать?
Arina Mokrousova: Контент, план, маркетинг, сентябрь, октябрь, семиотика, для, энджера семеотика для Эджера, Можно Найти?
O!Sapiens Expert: Чудащен, покая, сливе?
FANATIC Agency: Дичук?
FANATIC Agency: Наверно, не знаю но, маркетинг, действительно очень заботит?
FANATIC Agency: Максимально?
FANATIC Agency: Кажется, что, то у нас работает как, то, хуева?
Arina Mokrousova: Либо, может, нам, нужен не знаю ни маркетинг а. Пиар.
Arina Mokrousova: Там. Обычно?
Arina Mokrousova: В Агентствах есть отдельные маркетологи отдельной пиарщики?
Arina Mokrousova: Можешь?
Arina Mokrousova: Я просто. Не помню юлия она менеджер. По Маркетингу пиар она Выхватывает. Или нет?
O!Sapiens Expert: Хватывает части но, не Как классический пиар но пиар, пятики тоже не прям?
O!Sapiens Expert: До большей репутации. Нежили примушения, воронки?
O!Sapiens Expert: У тебя пиарщик не будет заниматься ни лингтоном ни инстаграмом ничем?
O!Sapiens Expert: Написанием статей, и колборациями?
FANATIC Agency: Антона Как У вас в издательстве вообще? Вот, Вся эта Система устроена как вообще, генерации, леды Вы Жел тоже По Факту бит убишники?
Антон Аверьянов: Это?
Антон Аверьянов: Да, ну там, есть просто камерческий отдел, который чья задача, продавать?
Arina Mokrousova: Это холодные, ну. Типа, Прямые, продажи, да?
Антон Аверьянов: Но, не совсем а, Там есть?
Антон Аверьянов: Партнерство с Фарпсон и их коммерческим отделом?
Антон Аверьянов: И там. Есть. Просто подготовленный. Медиакит И когда продажники Форб сой идут клиентам, они медиакит больших идей, несут?
Антон Аверьянов: И у нас есть заключенное партнерство. С Газпром, Медиа Холдингом. Они когда продают большие компании, которые охватывают те или к Радио, и так далее. У Них там есть партнеры которые, закрывают ну какую, то, контентную часть и сейчас будет большой спецы. Марк. Групп.
Антон Аверьянов: Это привел?
Антон Аверьянов: Газпром Медиахолдинг?
FANATIC Agency: А то есть, вы как части в сплите просто находитесь да.
Антон Аверьянов: Ну, Вообще, дату?
Антон Аверьянов: Да, да, да, да, да, да, да, да, да?
Антон Аверьянов: Но на би ту би продаже которые. Корпоративные Подписки. Есть отдельный человека который. Просто. Ходит. И, продает и созванивается, и пишет?
FANATIC Agency: Но Это продажа.
Антон Аверьянов: Но иногда на холодно. Да?
FANATIC Agency: А именно, вот маркетинг или, еще что, то нет ни по, колу?
Антон Аверьянов: Нет. Сейчас. Нут. Сейчас если. Под Коммерсант уедет издания то там, включится пол маркетинга пока эти Мне не. Занимались потому что большую часть выручки оборота приходится на Обетобе клиентов. На обетопе подпиской.
Антон Аверьянов: Это ручками ходить продавать, готовить, презентации, собирать, проекты, привернуть, также, как, в, агентствах?
Антон Аверьянов: Плат?
Антон Аверьянов: Я сейчас друга хотел сказать про то что, очень часто приходит пиарщики агенство. Как Расчета разместить я? Рассказывал что, из сигнала. Тогда приходили. Давайте. Разместим Статью про архитектуру но где редакция, не взяла недоработана была?
Arina Mokrousova: Угу?
Антон Аверьянов: Постоянно. Родная, речь приходит то, есть видно, что, перщиков, много агентства не ходит и они выходят?
Arina Mokrousova: Ну Да вот, они как, раз делают экспертные. Публикации Всякие выступления. На мероприятиях и это как бы. Да с, одной Стороны это. Типа просто, повышение. Доверия с. Другой Стороны всено, через медиа это ну Помогает. Привлекать. Льды, вот?
Arina Mokrousova: Просто Мы сейчас размещаемся преимущественно. У нас тоже есть экспертные публикации, но они преимущественно располагают как бы, на тех площадках, которые?
Arina Mokrousova: Ну. Типа скорее, не то чтобы, их, можно, назвать медиа которые привлекают, люды?
Arina Mokrousova: Дождь. Понятно, почему пятно?
FANATIC Agency: Вот посмотрим черном. Тэ. Т. Принесет. Площадка Т?
Arina Mokrousova: Вот этит, который бизнес секреты, или как они? Там называют?
FANATIC Agency: Да, да, да?
Arina Mokrousova: Но они тоже такие. Мы же публиковались. В них тоже тоже скорее наверно.
Arina Mokrousova: Подкачка просто доверие и репутации. Ну. Как, бы нели до генерации там. Нет аудитории этой?
Arina Mokrousova: Которая принимает решение?
FANATIC Agency: У меня последний этот антон. Ты Что, Же по моему читаешь этого, макса и, редмат? Робот Господи как? У. Него, фамилия?
Антон Аверьянов: Да, да?
FANATIC Agency: Он же очень много пишет. Вообще. Про маркетинг в. Би. Ту. Би. Вообще про структуру маркетинга в агентствах и. Вот. Это. Вот все у него прям большой ну пул. Это, посвящен?
Антон Аверьянов: Доп?
FANATIC Agency: Может попробовать к нему. Там. Я не думал что в него консультация стоит. Бешеных. Денег может попроботь. К Нему сходить и эту тему, как то пощупать?
Антон Аверьянов: Способ, да не разместиться, а просто поговорить с ним?
FANATIC Agency: Да, Да, у него же есть консультации он ну фаундров консультирует по, всяким. Как. Бы, темам и. Про маркетинг у, негон. Про продажи. Про Вот это. Вот, все.
Антон Аверьянов: Давай у меня в где тоже, кому осталось в прямом контакте. Выключить?
Arina Mokrousova: Да как бы, в целом мы же понимаем, что надо делать, но мы можем сходить к Нему но, я просто Думаю он нам скажет то что мы, и так знаем типа да ну да. Типа. Пиар Через Фаундеров, продвижение. Экспертов. Делиться. Экспертизой на. Оружие, светить людей, там и так далее. Это как бы классик?
O!Sapiens Expert: Это же, самое будет?
FANATIC Agency: То же самое?
FANATIC Agency: А. В чем?
Arina Mokrousova: Да?
FANATIC Agency: В чем тогда проблема в том что нас, них, ну, как. Бы. У, нас юля не проактивная или в чем?
Arina Mokrousova: Не. Я не говорю что, юля, не Проактивная и я, говорю, что это часть, это часть всегда завязана на людей юля Не может если, у людей нет времени люди, не может на это влиять но, у юли есть лучше разных инструментов что делать? В маркетинге, в. То время когда, люди не могут ходить выступать писать экспертные, статьи, и делать вебинары?
Антон Аверьянов: Да?
FANATIC Agency: Угу?
Arina Mokrousova: Вот.
Arina Mokrousova: Просто мы его не используем. Это инструментарий. Я не понимаю как вообще выглядит коммуниционная стратегия наша? В плане? Есть не знаю, там, платные каналы. Есть собственные каналы. Есть заработанные вот. Это. Как Бы модель классическая которая обычно пользуется. Все там весь морком и, так, далее?
Arina Mokrousova: У нас. Как бы, как будто?
Arina Mokrousova: Из каждого блока. По чуть чуть Он как бы, не, работает на полную мощность там можно. Еще. Как бы искать какие то варианты? Вот просто. Они должны быть более прицельными. Я вот говорю например, ну?
Arina Mokrousova: На тинькофф В журнале там. Как, бы нет этой аудитории?
Arina Mokrousova: Поисковик. Нас Там начали смотреть и таки А. Но. Это какие то нормальный, ребята нихтут, повлекаться там публикация там нофорпсе типа. Норм. Но как бы, надо размещаться, там, где люди, в Принципи нас увидят, и где есть какой То Симиол, и директор по Бренду, который так?
Arina Mokrousova: Это чу зачел, новые какие, то, надо типа, вообще про них посмотреть?
Arina Mokrousova: Это не происходит на тех площадках, где мы сейчас разлучаемся.
O!Sapiens Expert: Обычные деньги, размещения, неплатные?
Arina Mokrousova: Нет?
O!Sapiens Expert: Да?
Arina Mokrousova: Ват?
Arina Mokrousova: Ликиды Навести инстаграм Ввести бесплатно например?
O!Sapiens Expert: Ты. Сейчас про. Какие, да? Нет?
O!Sapiens Expert: Дожди. Про линктон Мы. Выяснили что, это два месяца пока, мы никуда не сдвинулись инстаграм мы не. Рассматривали?
Arina Mokrousova: Это понятно, Да, смотреть, еще еще надо смотреть но рассматривай, значит, Надо?
Arina Mokrousova: Я думаю, надо быть гипчей и, как, то, ну типа менять стратегию, если мы видим, что Меняется конферкт, внешний, вот?
O!Sapiens Expert: Надо просто куришь. Про кид конкретные, блат, Формы, или, площадки или это скорее в, общем?
Антон Аверьянов: Окей?
Arina Mokrousova: Не понимал вопрос Тв?
O!Sapiens Expert: Ты, Говоришь, про то что надо размещаться там где условно говоря, о, нас, увидят, и где сидят в, семье, мы судили, две площадки ты. Говоришь. Про Них конкретно или то в, целом?
Arina Mokrousova: А, да?
Arina Mokrousova: В целом про, них в том числе но в, целом вообще то есть они, ну как бы. Есть игру мы сами. Себе. От Цекли рейтинге?
Arina Mokrousova: Вот и присутствие там всяких каталогах. Это реально. Ми неерит. Большое количество трафика?
Arina Mokrousova: Большой количество, трафик генри трейтинги, и кейса, на сайте вот?
Arina Mokrousova: И публикация этих кейсов, в где, то, на каких то ресурсах. Вот?
O!Sapiens Expert: Угу?
Arina Mokrousova: Просто я понимаю, что у нас как бы вы мне можете сказать у? Нас нет? Бюджета Вот Юля, Скажешь, Ну, У нас нет специалиста. Все спецы заняты и?
Arina Mokrousova: Не могут заниматься перым чем, то еще но, как, бы это не знаю мышление из. Ограничения Ну хорошо. Все получается. Нам как, бы маркетинг не нужен что там, мы пишем там, какие, то Пару публикаций, в телеграм канале, но как? Бы, если мы, их перестанем писать. Ничего Не произойдет?
Arina Mokrousova: Надо писать один раз в месяц чтобы, просто. Люди знали что мы, не умерли все?
FANATIC Agency: Мы не умерли?
Arina Mokrousova: Ну, Да, прошу. Было видно что, там какая, то жизнь идет с кейсо делаваются. Проекты делаются, там какая, то есть вот.
Arina Mokrousova: Просто Как быть суть в том что, если, вот, упереться в эти. Ограничения типа мы, не можем платить за продвижение и у нас заняты люди, на проектах, Но все бездездок, тогда получается, как было какой смысл?
Arina Mokrousova: Заниматься маркетингом?
O!Sapiens Expert: Угу?
O!Sapiens Expert: Да, да, не понятно?
O!Sapiens Expert: Вопрос антон С Юлией или Во Всем?
Антон Аверьянов: В понедельник, в пять?
FANATIC Agency: Да, да?
Антон Аверьянов: Там обсудить?
O!Sapiens Expert: К.
FANATIC Agency: Влате то, что когда туда добавить?
O!Sapiens Expert: Часы. Гляну смогу ли. Я. Понедельник ближайший который, тридцать, первая, да?
O!Sapiens Expert: В, Пять, Да, с полов?
O!Sapiens Expert: Давай?
Антон Аверьянов: Окей?
FANATIC Agency: Катя На Завтра на четырнадцать тридцать голосовал. Стрендж поставил?
Arina Mokrousova: Супер! Спасибо?
Антон Аверьянов: Да, хочу.
FANATIC Agency: Все?
O!Sapiens Expert: Максимом?
Антон Аверьянов: Да посы большое давно, связа?